these are the mugshots sent worldwide of
a fugitive American police claim as a
serial sex attacker they say Nicholas
Rossi is a dangerous criminal who faked
his own death someone who attempted to
set up a hoax memorial service
dormant of this Manhunt arrived this
week here in Edinburgh the Americans say
he is Rossi a fraudster who uses aliases
to evade his predatory sexual history
last December in a coma with covert in a
Glasgow Hospital someone calling himself
Arthur Knight was arrested on an
Interpol warrant poor eyes I know a
sheriff has finally ruled who the man
behind the mask truly is
I am ultimately satisfied on the balance
of probabilities by the evidence of
fingerprint photographic and tattoo
evidence taken together
supported by the evidence of changes of
name that Mr Knight is indeed Nicholas
Rossi would you show us your arms
your biceps
okay I'm not getting him those tattoos
were key in reaching today's identity
Milestone something he was previously
hesitant to discuss with Sky News
he's holding me up against the wall he
is at the very heart of this are the
victims Mary whose identity we're
withholding is one attacked by Rossi in
Ohio in 2008.
I will remember those like chubby
fingers anywhere you know they were up
my shirt they were down my pants like I
would recognize those anywhere like his
greedy little claws
this has been one of the most bizarre
cases ever heard in a courtroom in this
country Nicholas Rossi who showed no
emotion here today concocted A String of
excuses all of which were contradicted
by expert Witnesses this week he tried
to suggest his body had been tattooed
while he was unconscious in a coma for
Coronavirus he tried to suggest his
fingerprints were taken by an NHS
employee called Patrick and sent to a
corrupt official in the United States
each and every argument was debunked and
dismissed here today as scandalous and
implausible
Miranda appears you've been lied to for
his wife has been by his side as this
trouble intensified and the net
tightened
but it's a troubled future which could
now lie ahead as the bid to extradite
this man gains fresh momentum Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh